foreign
you're his wife and you are digging a
hole in your backyard and burying
yourself in it so that you don't have to
face reality that your husband sucks
[Music]
what's up this is John with Dr John
deloney show
the greatest parenting and marriage and
mental health podcast ever ever ever
and you found us
whether a friend sent you this link or
you were searching for something on the
Internet or you just stumbled across Us
on YouTube
or you just woke up one morning and the
cosmos said you should look up this
quasi-clown who has a podcast about
mental health and marriage impaired
however you found us you did I'm so glad
that you were here if you want to be on
the show give me a call at
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask sorry for Sarah the editor you got
to cut all this stuff out because I
don't know how to do radio or podcasts
that's my new tune all right let's go to
Linda in Kansas City what's up Linda
Hi how are you I'm so good how are you
I'm doing fine thanks it's I'm I'm an
honor to talk to you sir thanks for
taking my call I'm super honored to talk
to you and
for those of you who don't know who you
wouldn't know
um I hung up on Linda I had a screwy
intro we have to edit out that you'll
never hear but Linda you heard it also
I'm glad you're sticking around with us
well thanks I'm gonna figure out how
this thing works at some point good
grief all right so what's up
um okay so I have a question
um I'm doing a lot of research I just
kind of need an answer is sexting
cheating that's kind of my big question
and so although
listen listen
you've you heard the show before have
you been I mean Have you listened to
show before
yeah a lot okay
so you'll understand what I say a lot
it's rare that somebody just walks up
and puts a ball right on the T for me or
or just throws an underhand pitch and so
on behalf of all of humanity and
especially me thank you thank you so
explain this explain your question a
little bit more okay so my husband and I
have been married for seven years we
have four kids six four three and almost
two oh good God almighty okay so you
live in a blender
um and a couple of months ago I was on
my husband's phone working for an email
confirmation for Netflix or audible or
something like that and the first text
message that I saw was good morning baby
I'm like that's a little weird so I
looked a little bit in his form a little
bit more and I saw some flirty pictures
and some sorority texts and still I
thought that's a little weird so I
checked Snapchat and some other social
media and there were naked pictures of
nine other women
it's really weird that's not normal
right so I brought it up into our
counseling session because we are in
therapy and he admitted to sexting three
women over the last two years
I was you know absolutely devastated and
when I tried to talk to him outside of
counseling he got really upset and
really offended that I used the word
Affair and he says he didn't cheat
because there was no actually he had
never had actually had sex with anyone
else
uh but he has hung out with several of
them in person before and after the
sexting cheated in a group setting and
and one-on-one with a couple of them so
is is sexting cheating is this is it
worse when the women aren't strangers
um are these Affairs or am I just
blowing this all out of proportion I
think you're crazy Linda I don't think
you have anything to worry about
like before I answer this are are you
I'm asking this I have I'm I have a
smile on my face but I'm not I'm not
being a jerk okay okay
like ask yourself this question pretend
that one of your girlfriends calls you
and was like hey I need to go get a
coffee
and she had snuck she had taken her
husband's phone
and it was full of these conversations
with other women naked photos of other
women
um confirmation that he was hanging out
with them
what would your answer to Herbie
Alex absolutely
one one
percent this is cheating
no if it's and this I mean this is
Gaslight I mean the gaslights are
burning so bright here because you are
the one walking around feeling like
you're crazy but then I think like who
am I to say who he can and can't text
who am I to say who he can't hear you're
his wife
wife
that's why
and when I married my wife
I invited her in to have a say into my
life forever
that's what marriage is
now even if we've been in survival mode
for the last five years with BBs and
toddlers And I'm not as I'm not as
pretty as or as thin as I used to be is
it okay for him to get visual
stimulation from Sexting in strip clubs
or again is that
still cheating Linda what happened with
you
why do you think so little of yourself
it's been a rough couple of years yeah
but I mean
where where is this coming from
you're the mother of four incredible
kids
this is
I mean I I don't even I I I'm you've
listened to show I'm speechless I don't
have words
this isn't about well I don't look how I
used to you have four children under six
and under this is this is the moment
that a husband steps up and rallies
around his wife and and through the The
Crucible through the uh challenge of
having four little ones you become more
unified than ever and you got to figure
out how to do a completely new life
because life before four kids was
chaotic and y'all could just have sex
whenever and you could leave clothes all
over the house and your bras hanging
from a ceiling fan and your husband
doesn't know his pants or that was that
life and it was awesome
and now you got a bunch of children
and you could still have that life but
you got to plan it right and it's got to
be it's just a totally different way of
being
this isn't for you to be like well that
was fun for that 18 months before we
started having kids and now I'm just
ugly and not worth being loved and I
should high-five him as he heads out to
hook up with these women and by the way
a thousand percent he's lying to you of
course he's hooked up with them
that's insane it's Madness
hooked up as a like yes
okay yes
I mean I I I mean I can't imagine a
scenario
and there's some anonymity if you will
to strip clubs or some anonymity to
pornography that's a whole other
conversation okay
this is people he's in relationship with
he hangs out with them he has dates with
him when a when someone goes out
one-on-one with somebody that they've
exchanged naked photos with that's
called the date
okay he's actively dating women that's
not you
and I like
I don't say I'm defending him but it
sounds like you've given him permission
well when you put it like that kind of
yeah but he has he said he's he's cut
off all contact with three of the nine
and so
I mean Linda Linda Linda listen
you are getting the world you're
allowing
if you want a husband
who
is about integrity and Fidelity then
that's the world
that um
I wish I had a better word for it that's
the world that's the world you demand
that's the world you say I'm I'm worth
and if you want a husband that's got
nine girlfriends on the side
then knock your lights out
but you might as well go ahead and file
for divorce now
just call it
because you're going to torture yourself
at the altar if I'm not pretty enough or
I'm not good enough or I used to be but
now I'm not
and you're worth so much more than that
and by the way
your kids are watching this they're
absorbing this this is what marriage and
love looks like this is what commitment
and I'll be with you till the end of
time through sickness and health they're
absorbing this oh sweet when she gets
when she gains weight
you go get some on the side
when you gain weight you have to let
them go because you're no longer Worthy
of integrity and fidelity
go ahead I'm sorry I cut you off go
ahead
is it reasonable for me to expect to
talk about this outside of our weekly
therapy sessions
I mean the fact that you're asking this
question tells me
this relationship's so over
yes you can talk about this anytime
for it in any place in I mean
I like why would you ask that question
are you safe is he abusive
no he just has like a lot of anxiety
when he talks about it
all anxiety is as an alarm
and of course the alarms are going off
because he's caught he's busted and he's
got a pretty sweet deal right now he's
got a live-in nanny for his four kids
and he's got nine girlfriends on the
side
and so anytime that little world gets
threatened of course his anxiety alarms
are going to go off
but that I can't talk about it it makes
me anxious shut up get over yourself
that's bullcrap and I've got anxiety I'm
clinically diagnosed so I can say it's
bull crap
foreign
you up like a Christmas tree with the
gaslights my sister
I don't think you are able to and I
don't it's I understand okay
I don't think you are in a place
where you can wrap your head around the
reality of your of your marriage and the
situation you find yourself
and I don't know who told you
that you had so little value
but they lied to you and they were wrong
you are worth so much more and by the
way I'd be saying this if he was sitting
on the phone I'd be saying this if he
was sitting right here at this desk
the way he's treating you is disgusting
it's unbelievable
and I'm sorry
when I say it do you do you believe it
or do you think I'm crazy
and it makes I
makes me feel a lot better than not
going crazy
I'll make someone said that to me in a
while what are you gonna do what does
your counselor say for God's sakes
um we haven't really addressed if it's
cheating or not cheating quite yet
Hey listen you need to find a new
therapist
and I and I'm I I'm saying that directly
and I I would say that the therapist
who's sitting right here
it's cruel that's the the old guard of
therapy is you just sit there and you
play referee while two people kind of
say their thing and it kind of comes out
and what all of the emergent literature
suggest is that's cruel because you
watch one person
drown somebody in a session
and the new the new way to do it my
buddy calls it wave three of therapy as
people were figuring out how human
beings work right which is really just a
laughable way of like we're finally
being
um wise
is you take sides you call it out
I'm gonna stop you right there sir
you're having a sexual relationship with
nine different people
and you're married to her
see what I'm saying I I'm sorry that
your counselor has just let this go on
that's nonsense
absolute nonsense
so sexing is a sexual relationship and
just unequivocally never for a second
doubt that as long as you live as much
as I'm sitting here wearing a black
shirt with buttons on it
sexting somebody is engaging in a sexual
relationship
period
there is no discussion there
is that new it can't be news to you
Linda
no it's not I just
and Rose colored glasses on and so I
just want to see like it's not really
it's not really cheating it's not really
because there's a lot online there's
four little kids on the line yes
and you are digging a hole in your
backyard and burying yourself in it
so that you don't have to face reality
that your husband sucks
Fair
yeah
fair
I'm sorry man I'm I mean I'm with I'm
I'm heartbroken for you
I can't I can't wrap my head around how
it got here
I would recommend
with all of my being that you go see a
counselor on your own
foreign
because
you are entering into you would be
entering into marriage therapy it's such
a distorted power differential
you think so little of yourself
that it's
you have been told probably for most of
your life
that you have so little value
or your only value is in a few things
and then we had kids and so they're gone
for the time being and so la dee da and
it's it's gonna it's it's kind of like a
um uh extension cord trying to go into a
plug in the wall the plug in the wall is
so
messed up that we're gonna have to we're
gonna have to go to an electrician and
have them pull it out and help rewire
this thing
because you have to be able to look in
the mirror and say I'm a person worthy
of being loved
and I'm a person worthy of there's chaos
in my home and there's gonna be for a
while
how can we have romance romance and
sexual intimacy and fun and laughter and
flirtation all that how can we create
that world inside of the chaos of
diapers and clothes everywhere and
random socks and some kid just peeing
all over the place like how do we do
that inside of that and that is
what strong marriages do
is they see the challenge ahead and they
choose to enter into it they lock arms
even tighter
and there is chaos and bumps and bruises
along the way
because we keep remembering back to the
way it was that season's over
gotta build a new a new thing moving
forward
[Music]
but my big my bigger concern here
is you just summon through your
husband's phone
with pictures of nine different women
he's meeting with and who are sending
him naked pictures and
who he's having dates with
and you think something's wrong with you
hear me say this
you're worth more than this
[Music]
if I can do anything to help you along
the way I'll be here let me know we'll
be right back
hey deloney here hey you know a while
back Society went off the rails and
people started to see sleep as like an
annoyance it's something in the way
right just chug another energy drink and
keep hustling and grinding my friends
sleep is not the enemy it's essential to
the way our minds and bodies function
and there are several things you can do
right away to start getting better sleep
first lay off the caffeine especially
after like 10 or 11 A.M and ditch the
screens at least an hour before bed and
I recommend getting a great mattress and
you can get a great mattress from my
friends at dreamcloud I speak from
experience here the right mattress can
make a huge difference in your sleep
quality it's why my family sleeps on
dream Cloud their mattresses are
designed to be soft and cool and
supportive so you can sleep comfortably
all night and right now dream cloud is
offering my listeners 25 off your order
plus 50 in additional savings and 500
199 bucks in accessories when you use
promo code John deloney that's cooling
pillows luxury sheets and a mattress
protector so go to dreamcloudsleep.com
and use code John deloney today
all right uh we're back hey during the
break I that last call the whole Booth
back there everyone's just speechless
except for all the yelling they were
doing
um and Joe the engineer had a sound
engineer had a great question that I
wish I had asked
um man sometimes I'm driving home and I
think I should ask this and I should
have asked this question to Linda
what would your husband say
if he were to grab your phone
and you were sinning and receiving nude
photos to nine different men
would he be like cool
that's awesome you should go hang out
with them
already loses mine
because his property doesn't doesn't do
that
if you ever feel in like
um you think you're not crazy but the
person you're in a relationship with is
making you feel crazy just ask yourself
what would they do if the tables were
turned
the exact same thing was happening but
it was you that was doing it not them
and that's usually a good answer that
you're not crazy
all right let's go I'm just gonna
Kyle you're gonna pick me back up
brother let's go to Kyle in Philadelphia
where you're born and raised and the
playground is where you spent most of
your days what's up dude
how you doing good hey I need you I need
you to I need you to rescue me here
what's up
um I guess I just had a question
um where uh if you hey if you were to
just be like listen I've been sexting a
lot and I just want to know if that's
cheated that would be incredible but
hopefully that's not what you're asking
what's up that's not me
um my question is so I'm a 27 year old
man I'm still trying to figure out you
know my life together just you know with
career and stuff
um but I ended up meeting a girl
um and it as far as my past relationship
she's a walking green flag like
everything about her is just great
but the issue that I'm having is the
walking green flag it's a good way to
put it um and she's great she's super
super cool super funny super cute like
everything is just everything's great
but the issue is that uh she has a kid
and
that's kind of where I wanted to speak
with you about it because I need some
help I need some advice here
what disqualifies an amazing woman
from being amazing just because she has
a child
nothing my thing is that that's why I
kind of want to mention like I said I'm
27 I'm still trying to figure out my
life
um and that's where it's like you know
that's something that it's just
I don't picture get to it you are
circling the wagons homie just get to it
and here's the deal when you say it out
loud you know you're gonna sound bad
just say it anyway let's get to it
I just think I'm not ready for okay
break up with it right now break up with
her right now
um break up with it right now
because this amazing woman doesn't come
without her kid in fact she'd be a
terrible human being if she ditched her
kid for you
and you don't want to be a dad cool
she's not the one for you right now
have enough decency and enough
respect for you for her for that sweet
little kid of hers to call it
and to have the Integrity to say
everything about you I love I am not
ready to be a dad
yeah
look at that that's the thing it's like
I'm not I'm not a hundred percent
against it and that's kind of you have
to be a thousand percent for it
you can't partly be in in a parenting
role
I get that it's all all all in
and I've got a buddy I was I was out on
a hunt trip the other day with a buddy
in the middle of the the frozen tundra
up north who married somebody adopted
um
uh her son right away
and years later their relationship's
amazing he's an amazing dad he he's
always been with with I mean he's always
been
um married to her and Dad that's how
they start the relationship and it's
awesome and and it's hard it had some
complexities there's some challenges
along the way no question about it
but you want both
you want her you want a fantasy version
of her
and that person isn't real and when we
project fantasies onto other people it
ends in Ash and a lot of broken hearts
and this time there's a kid don't do
that
and I and that's kind of why I wanted to
speak with you about it because I kind
of wanted like you said like it's hard
like I kind of wanted to
I I have no idea what it would be like
because like we're still very new like
we're not even dating yet like we've
just been going out on dates but you
know we've been clicking very hard where
um we've been seeing each other a lot
and she's super like understanding she's
like she tells me at any point if it
gets too much with like her custody
schedule or anything like that like she
will be willing to she understands if I
can't do it like I said to you like I'm
not 100 against it I just like I have
never seen myself in this position
before so I kind of want to see like
what is the
what I am signing myself up for if I do
do this because like I obviously have no
idea
I don't think any parent who has kids or
adopts kids fully knows what they're
signing up for until they're all in
because if we did we'd probably there'd
be moments when we
we opted out that's that's that's the
that's the deal
right
that's the deal and so
again you you won't have a tryout period
you want to practice
and that's not fair to her and it's not
fair to that kid
I think I I 100 I mean I get that you
this is not how you drew it up right you
were gonna meet somebody and then you're
gonna fall in love and you're gonna be
married for seven or eight years then
you might have a kid or what I I get
that or I'm never gonna have a kid I
have no interesting kid
um that totally makes sense that's the
same as I fell in love with somebody and
we ended up moving into Nebraska I'd
never had that plan I thought we're
gonna live in New York City for that
life happens that way that's okay
where it's not okay is when you fully
understand oh I didn't expect this and
here it is
and I only want part of this
then you got to let the rest go you
gotta let all of it go or you gotta say
I'm a hundred percent in
um and I get that
what'd you think I was gonna say because
you don't like my answer what'd you
think I was going to say yeah I don't I
don't I don't have a problem with your
answer it's because I like I said I and
I'm 27 so all my friends are the same
age as me and none of them have ever
dealt with this so it's like when I talk
to somebody about it
they give me the you know what are your
friends telling you
um well my closest friends like oh I can
so see you as a step dad like they make
a joke out of it but uh
um
obviously it's a big Challenge and they
all say they couldn't do it
um
with me like I said I'm not against it
I'm not 100 against it like I'm not I
have not
when we first started it was a it was a
fling we both like had it we talked to
each other we both were just like we are
not looking for anything serious but
we immediately clicked and
so I knew from the start that she had a
kid and
um and you hooked up with her anyway and
here you are
yes yes
so that and so either you're gonna have
to break somebody's heart
are you gonna have to choose to grow up
either way you've got a path that you
weren't expecting
absolutely
let me say if you choose to get serious
with her
you have to understand that her kid will
come first the kid has to come first
and you've got to know that
yeah I 100 know that and you've got and
not only know that but there has to be
not only okay with you that's got to be
awesome because that's the way it should
be
right right
I watched plenty of videos lots of read
articles like I I've I'm fully
understanding of
that part absolutely and you're gonna
have to make peace with her ax whether
that was a fling or they were married
before whatever
because that dude's gonna be part of
your life forever
yeah
just is and I've seen it done in so
incredibly well
like dads like
like go out and check in with each other
what are you seeing with our kid like
basically dads they're like hey man we
got two sets of eyes on this on this kid
this kid's gonna get double love from us
and I've seen it handled so immaturely
that you would think there were middle
schoolers involved they're so dumb it's
my toys I'm taking my trucks and going
home it's just so lame so if you're in
call the dude and ask him out for dinner
and say I'm gonna be a part of this
woman's life I love this woman I want to
honor your kid till the end of time
tell me what you're seeing tell me about
your boy tell me about what you want to
see like invite him in and if he chooses
to act like a middle schooler you can't
think about it
but at least you will take the high road
and see like I'm trying to paint a
picture for you dude I I would not
discount a single mom for anything
okay like there's nothing that
disqualifies her from being amazing and
awesome the question is do you want to
be a dad right now
and if you don't walk away man
and if you do be all all in
all right yeah that makes sense
and quit asking your buddies dude they
don't they don't they don't know man
that's why I wanted to speak with you
because I was like somebody that I
actually like I listen to you all the
time so I was like I trust I trust your
opinion enough but I could just give you
a call I appreciate that I appreciate
that I man I I wish you the best for
whatever and so number one make sure you
do this don't don't read the YouTube
comments on this because you're gonna
get all kinds of people throwing
grenades and all so just don't do that
the second is
I'm not going to fault you for not
wanting to be a dad at 27.
cool
where I will fault you is if you drag
this poor woman through it because y'all
keep hooking up
or if you kind of like hanging out with
her but you don't see a future to for it
but in some shape form or fashion you
lead her to believe that there is a
future
that's just cruel man don't do that
don't do that and that's not just single
women that's with anyone
and women that's with anybody you're
romantically attracted to just don't do
that just don't do that
[Music]
but man she sounds awesome
she's a walking green flag I've never
heard that that sounds like he's got
some kind of illness but I'm gonna trust
you that that means it's awesome
um
I don't know man got a hard decision to
make
just be a person of character integrity
when you make it we'll be right back
hey good folks John deloney here I feel
like I fell through a glitch in The
Matrix this is my job I get to have this
show do this show walk alongside each
one of you as a career this is what I do
and I have a blast doing it and me and
the team were so thankful for all of you
for being a part of our show whether
you're one of the original 17 or you're
one of the millions that's come since
then we are so grateful for you and we
want to put together the best possible
show that we can so if you're one of The
Originals or if you're brand new we want
your feedback tell us what you love
about the show what you hate about the
show would you like to see more of would
you like to hear more of and what you
want us to never do again you can email
us at askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's
ask John
ramseysolutions.com with your feedback
thank you for being such an important
part of the show rock on
all right we are back let's go to Lacey
in Buffalo New York what's up Lacy
Don thanks for taking my call of course
what's happening
um okay so I I wrote down a couple
thoughts so then I'll follow up with my
question if that's okay very cool
absolutely
okay so my call today is regarding my um
little sister-in-law we love her very
very much um but I recently found out
that she's been dabbling in cocaine
um and obviously this is very concerning
to us but equally concerning is a
pattern of behavior that we've witnessed
over the past few years with her
um she's only 21 but since she was
around 16 we've seen a lot of deception
in all of her relationships not just
with the family
um and on the outside right now it seems
like she's doing okay she's got a good
job working in finance she's got her own
place she's got a boyfriend
um she's pretty responsible
um but then we learn about things that
she's lying to us or lying to others
about and um I guess a terrifying thing
to us is that the lies seem to get
bigger and nothing is really slowing her
down and sadly I'm afraid that if we
talk to her about
you know the cocaine usage that she'll
just lie and deny that she's doing it
sure
um so my question is do we still try to
talk to her and if so what can we say
this one's hard
and unfortunately because of my previous
career I'm just man I had this
conversation a lot it's hard
yeah
um
how did you guys find out she's doing
coke
um a co-worker who's also a friend of
mine
um told me
gotcha what happened when she was 16 was
there stuff that went on in the family
did she have some abuse did she get with
have a boyfriend that got site like what
what happened there
five kids and um
um she got wrapped up with a boyfriend
when she was 16 and that's I think when
we started noticing some of the
destruction she had two phones one that
she would use to communicate with him
and he was
um much older than her okay he sounds
like he's older yeah yeah
and that's kind of how it all started
and then eventually she did move out um
when she was 18.
um kind of surprised everybody surprised
and not surprised we kind of knew it was
coming but how old was this guy
um he was like 22. yeah so I want to
contextualize this for everybody okay so
when it comes to
actually let me let me back up a little
bit okay
um
i s i because of my experience working
with young people and because of people
that I'm in relationship with that I
love that I would consider close to me
I do not screw around with
cocaine
okay it's it's um
that said I've I know multiple people
who say they only do it a couple times a
year like just recreationally
um and so I can't deny that I can't I
can't pretend that's not true that's
what they say
I can't and I know that we're we're the
countries being ravaged by an opioid
epidemic
but I've seen cocaine and its younger
cheaper sister math I've seen it just
destroy
right it just rages fire now here's the
catch what I learned over the years was
instead of
asking somebody why in the world are you
using cocaine
why in the world are you drinking the
cover up why in the world are you Phil
partying where in the world are you
whatever
I quit asking that question
and I started asking the question
what happened in your life
that made being you so painful that you
had to really go after some heavy stuff
to cover it up
yeah and
she could have had a very loving home
but she was raped and sexually abused
from the time she was 16 to 18 years old
by a 22 year old man
yeah
so you see what I'm saying
yes and I would definitely agree with
you except
um I don't I mean it was rape of course
but she was very much a participant in
all of that at the same time oh Lacey I
I mean I I definitely am not like
absolutely if I'm standing up for her
but yes she was a kid and so I would
challenge the notion with all of my
heart that she's got a quote unquote
really loving family because a really
loving family would have gone to war to
keep their daughter from being raped
does that make sense
yup yup police were involved okay
okay and um it was her choice she did
she did not want any she wanted to just
brush it under the rug
and um
so I mean that's I guess in
he had a there was like a restraining
order put out against him but
um and then she wanted to just move on
with her life so that's I think what
everybody just did because she was a
child
well and if
foreign
no that's messy
um
there can't be any lingering thought in
your mind in your husband's mind in the
family's mind that well she was asking
for it and she really wanted to go no we
don't think that that's what you said
yeah
like she was all in you know what I mean
yeah I mean we've this was over a couple
years and when we found out she was 18
um and at that time she was like I'm
moving out I'm making my own decisions
what's in the passes in the past you
know so
I mean and she was like this is this is
my the love of my life you know
so that's what I say when when she was
all in
um you know
so
I think the
but I mean since then like they've split
up she's been with other men of course
yeah I mean and I just feel like nothing
I I don't know what to tell her what to
say that we can try to just
um and even when we try to have
relationships I mean we see her all the
time she's over her family dinners you
know she loves coming around but I just
feel like it's very surface-b because
even when we just ask her simple things
like oh what'd you do this weekend it's
a lie I mean there's I can't I feel like
we can't have connection with her
because just even the little things are
just we find out later oh that wasn't
really entirely true and and
something in her body
says that none of y'all are safe
none of y'all are trustworthy
none of you will still love me if you
really knew
yeah
and so I've got to escape with drugs
I've got to keep everybody in the arms
length with dishonesty even as Wild As
It Gets
because from 16 to 18 these two people
who said they love me love me love me
love me had no idea that I was being
abused
nobody came and got me
and that sounds unfair and it sounds how
are we supposed to know we had five
other kids and blah blah blah
nobody came and got her
and she's gonna be chasing somebody tell
me that I'm worth being loved
that I've got value because the two
people are supposed to come rescue me
didn't show up yeah and it's easy to be
like well she keeps hooking up with so
and so and she keeps ended up with
another man another man her body is
Desperately Seeking somebody to say I
see all of you and I love you
yeah
and
um
the sucky thing about cocaine is it
works
it makes you
it lights up your brain like a like a
Christmas tree and you can work better
and faster than people and it works
until it kills you
yeah right and so
you are right on if you sit down and try
to have some Kumbaya conversation it's
not going to go very well or some sort
of after school special conversation
yeah it's not going to go well
um
the conversation to be had is a private
conversation probably with her brother
probably with Mom and Dad maybe with you
somebody say
I'm so so sorry
and
I love you and I love you and I love you
and you're always welcome here
more and more information is not going
to solve this problem it's not a data
issue
it's a connectivity issue
and she is a young
Beautiful Soul desperately searching for
somebody to say you're enough
yeah
is this ringing true
so I mean I don't know that's hard it's
hard
when we all find out found out because
at the time it was just a whirlwind of
what like we're just finding this out
she's moving out you know we're finding
the second phone we're finding all these
things
um and at the time she didn't want to
hear any of that you know she was just
like I'm on to my new man you know I
found this guy and and so I don't know
well that's what a great I had the
opportunity what a great rapist and a
great child molester will do
is
make a child feel like they can't
breathe without them
yeah and
they get so intertwined with shame and
purpose
and worth
and somebody exciting and new and sexy
and with their own jaw jaw and car
whatever
becomes so magnetic that just going home
and sitting down for dinner with the
family
I mean like it so it it's like me
getting mad at my daughter when I leave
jelly beans everywhere she's seven
like that's on me
right you know what I mean it I expect
her to want to eat jelly beans until she
can't fit another jelly bean inside of
her tiny little body
I expect that
it's up to me to say hey this isn't safe
this isn't healthy this is gonna make
you sick that's my job I'm dead
and so yes it's easy when you find an 18
year old or a 19 year old
to say oh my gosh you didn't follow our
family Rules you deceived us you lied to
us you had another phone you've been
sneaking out for years
I totally get that
yeah
and that's the
that response
is catastrophic
the response should be
God help us we missed it and I'm so
sorry we should have been there for you
and we weren't
understand that you got a second phone
that you did this and that you can tell
everybody in the world as a 16 year old
you wanted this and you wanted to do
this and blah I don't you don't get that
vote when you're 16 because you're a
child we missed it and I'm sorry
you're please come home
yeah does that make sense
so the whole family is gonna have to be
in on
that's not true that's not true because
there's going to be parents who cannot
they cannot take ownership in these kind
of moments they just can't
I've seen it too much I've seen it my
whole career parents who just can't
internalize that they have any role to
play in something like this
and brothers and sisters who say hey man
she made her choices
and
people who look at her and say dude she
was she was a flirt she was always
dressing this way and say stupid hateful
hard things like that
and the reality is I always want to go
back to that 16 year old girl
they needed somebody to step in and they
didn't so
at some point someone's got to step in
now
and that might be you that might be you
that might be you looking at her and
saying listen to me very carefully
I know
that your parents should have stood us
like stepped in and they didn't we all
should have stepped in yeah and we
didn't and I'm sorry that was wrong
yeah and I love you
yeah no I can definitely say that
um it may be a big brother too
yeah yeah
I felt I feel like I don't want to paint
them in a bad light because they
definitely were I mean it was a mix 50
50 of
um oh my gosh what's going on and we
love you please don't do this you know
what I mean so I definitely don't think
that that conversation wasn't it was had
but at that point I think she was
already kind of too far gone at that
point to listen but I'm hoping maybe now
um now that he's out of the picture and
you know
some years of that maybe instead of sit
down and have that conversation maybe
instead of her of looking at her like
she's too far gone
maybe looking at her like her body got
the message loud and clear no one was
going to pay attention
yeah
and so she went with the person that
paid attention
yeah
yeah no I mean I didn't mean like too
far gone like she's you know like I'm
superior or any any of that I just meant
she she was very invested into that
relationship absolutely and I wouldn't
think anything less I wouldn't think
anything less I'm imagining myself as a
16 year old and if some beautiful 22
year old woman had come and started
showing interest in me and telling me
that I was wonderful
right
I mean it would be ludicrous for me not
to be
like swooned by that
yeah so we have laws and people and
adults and all that stuff and so I I
can't I can't overstate
[Music]
how big of a miss this was
and I can't overstate
that not using the words sexual assault
and rape
not using those words
is a disservice to what happened
and I can't overestimate how this her
healing will not happen outside of
relationship and at some point she's
going to find them
[Music]
My Hope Is that they come from a place
that they are with people who love her
and have her best interests
and not who are just interested in
making sure the family looks good
and not keeping up the big loving and
we're all everything's wonderful and all
that kind of stuff
I hope it's from people who
take a knee and say
we missed it in our own house and I'm
sorry
foreign
[Music]
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right hey we're back um
I didn't think I had to take a minute
after that last call
um
that was hard
the children in our lives
can be whether they're four or seven or
sixteen
and I'll go as far as say 18 21. I know
they're quote unquote adults but
the kids in our lives
need adults
to love them
and to step in on their behalf
and to pay attention
and to get involved
and when the time comes go to war
and when you see your kid
lying all the time
when you see your kid
slipping into drug use you see your kid
running to other people
for affirmation
before you blame the child
just ask yourself behavior is a language
what are they trying to tell me what are
they missing here
this isn't to shame parents or to blame
parents or blah blah blah but I am
saying this parents
you gotta get involved
and for kids being abused
if your kids being assaulted
your silence tells them
all I need to know about their worth and
value or the fact that you don't even
know what's going on
get involved
and normally we end every show with a
song or song lyrics
and
I know
it didn't feel right today but
um I had somebody write in one time
and
it was doing a similar child abuse call
and I got upset and walked off set and
there was no song the show just ended
um this is this is maybe a year or two
ago and he wrote in and said something
poignant he said hey
um when you don't do song lyrics at the
end it leaves me untethered
as a listener I just find myself in the
car trying to put the pieces back
together after some of these tough calls
and so I've never missed one since
so not as a disrespect to this young
woman
who is left to fend for herself as a 16
year old but as a sign of respect and
honor for The Listener it is a hard show
it's a hard show
um
today's song is by Grace Potter and the
song is called release
I know that I caused pain and I know
that you can't let me go crying in the
midnight rain waiting on a miracle
I release you though it's hard to say
the words and I release you from holding
onto the bridge I burned I release you
from the darkness from the love that we
swore was true and I hope that someday
the sun will shine again and you'll
release me too
even if I'm in your arms even if you
touch my skin I could never change my
heart after being where it's been
I release you from the darkness
from the love that we swore was true and
I hope that someday the sun will shine
again and you'll release me too I love
you guys we'll see you soon